This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
Over the past 18 months, we've heard a lot about the human immune system.
The cells in our bodies that fight diseases like coronavirus.
We know that in humans, the bloodstream carries immune cells around our body.
But what about trees and plants? They don't have blood. So how do they protect themselves?
That's a good question, Sam. And the answer involves memory. Us humans
store memories in our brain, but our body also remembers things, including stressful
situations from the past, which it stores in our genes. The information gets passed on to our
children genetically.
But surely trees don't have memories, Neil. I mean, do you think a tree can remember being young
or what it was doing last year?
Well, not exactly, but trees grow rings, a layer of wood for each year of growth. That could be a
kind of memory. In this programme, we'll be asking whether trees can remember. And if so,
does it make them stronger and better able to fight disease?
But before that, I have a question for you, Sam. As I said, trees grow a new ring every year.
And by counting them, we can estimate their age. One of Earth's longest living trees is the great
bristle cone pine found on the west coast of America. But how long can these trees live?
Is it A? Over a thousand years? B? Over three thousand years? Or C? Over five thousand years?
Wow, it would be a job to count the rings on those trees. I'll say B. Over three thousand years.
Okay, Sam, we'll reveal the correct answer later.
And like us, trees don't have blood in bones to protect them from outside attacks.
So how exactly does a tree's immune system work?
That's what BBC World Service programme crowd science asked bioscientist Jury and Tom.
Here's what he said.
Plans in particular need to have a very efficient immune system for two important reasons.
Firstly, they sit at the bottom of the food chain. So there are a lot of opportunistic organisms out there,
including insect herbivores and microbial pathogens. We want to tap into that biochemical energy
that is stored in plants. The other reason is plants are rooted to the ground.
They cannot escape from the stressful conditions in their environment.
It's hard for trees to protect themselves. Unlike animals, they can't run away.
And they're at the bottom of the food chain. The plants and animals linked in a chain of
eating weaker things and then being eaten by stronger ones.
Rabbits eat grass and in turn are eaten by foxes.
Right. If you're at the bottom of the food chain, everything wants to eat you,
including opportunistic animals. If something is opportunistic, it takes advantage of a situation
to gain some benefit for itself. True leaves are opportunities for hungry insects and caterpillars
to eat. So trees need immunity because they're under attack, either from disease or from living
things wanting to eat them. But what about memory, Sam? If trees can remember stress,
types of insects that eat it, for example, they might be better prepared in future.
For me, stress is a work deadline or moving house, but for trees it's more basic,
something like not getting enough water. Dr Estrella Loonerdiets believes trees record stress in their
rings. A small ring showing that the tree didn't grow much that year indicates some outside stress.
She explained more to BBC World Service Programme, Crowd Science.
Our hypothesis could be that depending on the level of that stress, so if it was a really long
lasting drought of a few years, then maybe the tree can remember it for a long time because it needs
to adapt to that hostile environment. Now, maybe the hypothesis could be the other way around.
Like if it's maybe it was a very dry July, for instance. Maybe the tree is not even that
bothered. And then it forgets within one year because that memory of stress is going to be holding
it back on its growth, for instance. Dr Loonerdiets has a hypothesis, an idea that explains how
or why something happens, which has yet to be tested to see if it's correct. Her hypothesis is
that trees remember stressful outside events, something like a drought, a long period of time with
little or no rain. For a tree which has lived for hundreds of years, it might be useful to remember
that 1947 was a very dry summer. On the other hand, maybe that stressful year is best for Gossin.
Maybe the tree is not bothered, not worried or concerned because it's not important to it.
So trees do have memories, but they don't let it get them stressed. Maybe that's the secret to a
long life. But what's the answer to your question, Neil? Ah yes, I asked you how long Earth's
oldest trees, great bristle cone pines, can live. I said B, over 3000 years. What was I right?
You were wrong, I'm afraid Sam. They live even longer, over 5000 years, in fact,
all the way back to the Bronze Age. What memories those trees must have, if only they could speak.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned starting with immune system, the body's way of
fighting infection and disease. A food chain describes how plants and animals get eaten and eat
each other. Opportunistic people take advantage of a situation to get some benefit for themselves.
A hypothesis is an idea to explain how or why something happens that hasn't been tested to see
if it's correct. A drought is a long period of time with little or no rain. And finally, if you're not
bothered about something, you're not worried because it's not important to you. Our six minutes are
over. Bye for now. Bye.